newly leaked audio of joe biden isn't
going to sit well with the far left
biden pointing out the obvious to civil
rights leaders and blaming the defund
the police movement
for major democratic losses
they've already labeled us as being
defund the police
anything we put forward in terms of the
organizational structure
to change policing which i promise you
will occur
promise you just think to yourself and
give me advice whether we should do that
before january 5th because that's how
they beat the living hell out of us
across the country saying that we're
talking about defunding the police
we're not we're talking about holding
them accountable
holding them accountable by defunding
them we understand this emily
i get that what joe was saying is that
the republicans won
by simply amplifying the democrats
message
the the republicans didn't change any of
the message they just said hey look
your elite these leaders wanted to fund
the police that's all they did
totally he when he keeps saying they and
he means the gop
he should be referring to the far left
of his party
that's where it came from to your point
all we were doing all they were doing
was amplifying it back and also you know
frankly this doesn't surprise me right
this is sort of his his continued
talking point
it's the same one that obama said the
other week right when he said you're
losing big audiences the same time you
do this
it's the same rep clyburn said when he
said i'm not into sloganeering and all
you're doing
is exchanging headway for headlines
everybody in the party
sees that they are exchanging strategy
for holding on to this ideals but
look joe biden continuing to push that
narrative that what they actually mean
is just holding them accountable
it's not going to work in 2022 nor is it
going to work in january
dana the other point of this that wasn't
mentioned in that leaked
audio is that they were pushing this
idea while
denying what we were seeing with our own
eyes on the streets
of democrat cities with the chaos the
looting the arson
yeah and i don't know if you saw but in
minneapolis they went ahead
and they are actually defunding the
police so they'll have to
have that social experiment there
they've already had i think 170
officers who are either retired or
resigned
and look i wouldn't want to be in that
city right now and i feel for the people
that are because they're going to go
through a tough time
until it's going to become obvious that
they've made the wrong move here
the other thing i was thinking is that
we're going to be back to the days of
leaked audio
where as with president trump you just
had audio
he just did it with people on the phone
there's no leaking that is so true
he'll say it's rewarding geraldo so
you hit on this earlier the problem with
being a liberal progressive
is that you can't own your liberal
progressivism
see i i think it's a bit more nefarious
greg because to me it sounded as if joe
biden was saying
let's cool our jets until january 5th
and then we'll do
the defund the police we'll uh let's
talk the moderate talk
uh no it did not we're not really
defunding we just want to
you know modernize and uh and make more
moderate the police
but it it wasn't that it sounded to me
like he said just hang in there
january 5th we get georgia behind us
then we'll let them have it
you know it sounded uh it sounded kind
of ugly and political to me
that's a good point you know jesse i
fashioned a question just for you
i think that this points out the bizarre
contrast
between the down ballot fiasco of the
democrats
and joe still somehow winning as if they
overwhelmingly
rejected the democrats except for him
which makes no sense yeah it's one of
those head scratchers
and i'm losing my hair because i keep
scratching my head over this election
but i see this in a different way than
everybody here
i see joe as being a typical politician
who cares what defund the police did the
democrats
look what it did to the streets look
what it did to the police look what it
did to the neighborhoods
it destroyed those neighborhoods it's
like barack obama waits until his book
tour comes out
to start condemning defund the police
where was he the whole summer when the
cities were on fire
joe biden was bailing out to fund the
police riders and now he's worried about
the politics of it
and let me hear this out have you heard
one
thing about police reform from biden
first hundred days are they going to do
police reform the first time i even
heard them say
they're going to do police reform it is
is in leaked audio
so this just looks like to me you know
they play this big
police race thing every four years and
then they do nothing about it
and then they stoke the fire again
during before the next election
and then they drop it it's the same
cycle every time
i'm torn because this is such a great
point but jesse made the great point
so i don't know how to handle that just
reject it